[Music]  Kim Kardashian returns to Instagram sort  of she eats emoji know and love emoji  told me  Kim broke her social-media silence on  Wednesday creating an Instagram account  for the launch of her kimochi  merchandise set to release on December  16th naturally the reality stars  comeback involves posts that show a  whole lot of skin  featuring a twerk video and cleavage  baring pigs I love that from strippers  sweatshirts to middle finger move shirts  she's back in true Kim fashion I'm happy  and I feel confident though Kim has yet  to officially return to Twitter and  Instagram the Keeping Up with the  Kardashians star has remained low-key  about sharing online since her  terrifying Paris robbery in October and  her husband Kanye West's hospitalization  for exhaustion in November I feel like  we are so blessed to have the best  support system and the best family to  really just support each other no matter  what we're going through  you  you